what is going on everybody and welcome
to the return of the python plays grand
theft auto
series
so
what's changed what is this project if
you're not familiar with the project it
was from about five years ago
back when the open ai universe was set
to include uh grand theft auto 5 which
was such a cool sandbox if you don't
know what the universe was or is sort of
i'm not really sure it kind of was
anyway it was like a collection of
environments kind of like the open ai
gym i forget what necessarily
differentiated universe from gym but a
collection of environments for you to
train and play within with your ai so
this was set to include grand theft auto
5 but then it was pulled kind of um not
i don't know about last minute but kind
of after a while it seemed like they
were pretty close to having it done and
then all of a sudden it wasn't gonna
happen so
um around this time i started to wonder
like well do i really need any of this
can we not just use a screen recorder
essentially screenshot because
constantly the frames of the game
you can simulate key presses with
virtual key presses and obviously you
can read key presses with like any type
of key logger you want so so doing all
of this in python totally possible so
that was what spawned the original
python plays grand theft auto 5.
unfortunately this was a while back i
wasn't necessarily the best programmer
in the world and i didn't really know
all that much about deep learning this
was kind of my first big deep learning
project despite all that it actually
worked okay worked surprisingly better
than it should have in my opinion at the
time and in my opinion now it wasn't the
greatest driver ever
but it definitely learned stuff in the
game and that was really cool to see the
problem was all the data was created
manually by me and anytime you made even
the slightest change in that data so
maybe you want to change the driving
style the vehicle maybe you want to take
away there was a wonder about like the
mini-map how how big of a
importance is that mini-map to the agent
for figuring out where to go and then
later i thought well why not add
waypoints to give them like a purpose
every time you make a change like that
you have to recollect all of the data
all over again and i was doing this
manually by hand uh very very tedious
we're talking like 20 plus hours of just
playing gta but you're not really
playing you're you're working in gta
to make that driver so it wasn't really
the most enjoyable experience so what's
changed between then and now it's quite
a bit like i've learned a lot to daniel
who actually we we met over the python
plays gta series originally he's been
working with me ever since together we
wrote the neural networks from scratch
book we've learned a lot about deep
learning uh the just gpus in general
have progressed quite a bit we've just
really wanted to revisit this project
for
a long time and a few months ago the
company here kamino that built this
machine reached out and was curious
about getting me to review it and it has
four a100 gpus in it uh as soon as i saw
that they they were interested in
getting a review i was like i know
exactly what we have we must do with
this uh with this uh i don't know what
to call it it's like a it's not really a
computer it's a workstation but it's
even more than a workstation i don't
like a
data science center in a little box
so anyways they've been extremely
patient with us we've had it definitely
longer than uh was intended so thanks to
camino for that i also have quite a few
other machines which have come in handy
so one of the major changes from back
then until now is daniel has created for
us essentially like our own npc that
plays grand theft auto for us and logs
all of this data and we can tell this
npc what we want like how do we want it
to drive what you know what settings do
we want waypoints do we want to show the
minimap and all that so
this is a massive update uh just for me
to not have to make the data
but also it allows us to make data
faster so we can run as many of these
npcs as we can run gta 5 instances
also
this allows us to train a model live so
we have agents that are just constantly
playing this model and then we are also
constantly training this model so what
this means for you guys that are going
to
plausibly be tuning in to watch so we'll
be streaming it just like i did before
about 24 7 on twitch uh grand theft auto
seems to have like a memory leak or
something and it's it if you leave it up
long enough it is going to crash like
within 24 hours sometimes less sometimes
more so
close to 24 7 we'll we'll be trying to
stream this and unlike before when i
would train a model basically i had to
train a model and then update the model
that the agent actually playing the game
and streaming the game to twitch that
was a static model that model did not
change
unless i
you know unless i manually changed that
model basically it wasn't learning live
as it played the game in this case uh
the play the agent that is playing is
playing on the most recent up-to-date
model whatever it is that we're training
and it is constantly being updated and
this has been really really fun just as
we've been trying to prepare and get
everything ready for the stream we've
been training different models and and
just seeing them grow and change like in
real time is really cool i mean
obviously you see like your loss curve
go down or something but very rarely do
you get to see like a constant
representation of where is your model
right now uh and it's been really fun to
watch so hopefully if you tune into the
stream you should be able to tune in
especially if it's a newish model you
should be able to tune in like a few
hours later and it should be a little
different and then as it matures it
might take days or something to to get
actually much better from the previous
point but our intention here is to spend
a little bit more time streaming like
the model's growth over time and the
changes and all that and then also we'd
like to be showing things like
visualizations of the neural network so
like the training and all that as it's
happening live as well as things like
visualizing the convolutional layers uh
and so on so um i wouldn't come to the
stream expecting to see like a really
good self-driving car uh self-driving
cars is almost like a general
intelligence problem rather than just a
simple supervised learning task or
something like that i mean we billion
dollar companies haven't solved it now
we have a trillion dollar company that
still hasn't solved it self-driving cars
were uh one to three years away five
years ago and i would say i'm pretty
sure we're still saying they're one to
three years away today so it's a very
hard challenge but it's very fun and uh
the the actual like growth is is pretty
linear so even if you don't have a
perfect driver uh you can still see that
oh it's actually making attempts to do
cool things so uh and it's at least okay
it just might crash once in a while
which is fine in grand theft auto it's
just not quite fine for real life so uh
we have it a little easier we can have a
little more fun with it and all that so
anyways
we at the time of my release of this we
will be live on twitch.tv slash centex
so come check it out uh watch the model
grow we'll that isn't going to be like
the only model that we train we're going
to try to tweak things um add different
concepts to it right now it's mostly
visual we don't really have any other
sensor data that's coming in we could
add things like speedometer or proximity
sensors that kind of stuff also like
historical data right now it's just
frame by frame so we have lots of ideas
that we want to test but i really just
wanted to get it out get the stream out
because each time we test our ideas like
i said even as we've been building it uh
it's really cool to like watch the model
grow and kind of see what are the
differences between these models uh and
all that so anyways definitely come
check out the stream if you're
interested in this sort of thing it's
just it's just cool to watch it watch it
grow and change over time uh and then
also if you have any ideas suggestions
all that we'll
certainly be open to input from people
so
anyway that's it come check us out on
twitch.tv slash syntax otherwise i will
see you guys in another video
or on the stream